[Music]
being the only boy in the family is
tough but what's even tougher is having
10 strong-minded sisters let's be honest
Lincoln has to put up with a lot but
there are a couple of times when we were
truly shocked by his sister's behavior
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
the times Lincoln couldn't deal with his
sister's white hair white hair is one of
the most interesting episodes of the
loud house because it introduces the
original concept of the loud family and
in case you're not familiar with it the
loud family was originally meant to be a
family of rabbits but this entire
episode just showcases how much Lincoln
has to deal with when it comes to his
sisters Lincoln wants to find out a way
to change himself to impress a girl and
of course his sisters want to help but
he knows very well what happens when his
sisters try to intervene with basically
anything so he sneaks out we won't spoil
it all for you but that alone is an
example of Lincoln refusing to deal with
his sisters and then there are of course
the rabbits because what's worse than
having ten sisters having 25 sisters it
only gets worse as you watch the episode
of course it's all masked and jokes and
humor but we really feel for Lincoln
throughout this episode it's not easy
being the only boy in the family and
Lincoln knows it but overall this
episode does eventually end on a
positive note
when Lincoln realizes the importance of
being himself and just be you making the
grade making the grade is a frustrating
episode for a lot of loud house fans we
all know the loud sisters love to
intervene with Lincoln's life but this
is one of these few times we've seen
them in school having Lisa as your
classmate is something no one
once sure she's adorable with her large
glasses but she's also incredibly smart
and this started threatening Lincoln's
popularity in school
Lincoln's friends actually turned their
backs on him because they realized how
much better Lisa was we're telling you
this is the stuff nightmares are made of
and to make things worse Lisa decided to
change herself because being smart
wasn't cool anymore
Lincoln's face just displayed shock
throughout the episode we also see Lisa
blaming Lincoln because of her change
from smart to not so smart the loud
sisters even kick him out of the van
after Lisa was unable to answer a
geology question you can kind of tell
Lincoln was done with his sisters during
this episode but you couldn't tell how
upset some fans were unless you went on
to read some of the loud House blogs
seriously this episode isn't a fan
favorite and there's good reason behind
it why is everyone being so mean to
Lincoln get it
serial offender speaking of most hated
episodes in the series serial offender
also rubs people the wrong way if you
have a lot of siblings you know how this
episode makes you feel first of all
Lincoln's parents didn't allow him to do
the grocery shopping all by himself even
though he was totally capable of it but
we have no idea why they thought
bringing his sisters along would make
the experience run any smoother Lincoln
actually ends up getting all the
groceries despite his sister's just
messing around but then he gets kicked
out over something he didn't even do and
he didn't even end up getting the cereal
he wanted his mom even scolded him in
the van even though it really wasn't his
fault at all seriously if you ever had
siblings you know how painful this
episode was to watch we've really felt
for Lincoln and he definitely didn't
deserve the treatment he was getting
sometimes the loud sisters are a little
bit much but don't worry we're just
getting started there are plenty of more
episodes in which Lincoln just couldn't
deal with his sisters and we really felt
for him the loudest yard we've discussed
this episode plenty of times as there
are several problematic moments in it
that don't make it suitable for kids but
overall the loudest yard is also a clear
example of how
yeardley the loud sisters treat their
brother in this episode Lincoln's
parents desperately wanted to stay away
from video games so they sign him up for
a football team of course Lincoln's not
a football player so he gets Lola to
play for him in fact he asks Lola if she
could break his leg so he could injure
himself and not play at all
of course Lola agrees and decides to
drive her princess car over his leg but
at the last minute Lincoln changes his
mind and Lola ends up crashing seriously
this is an actual episode the part
that's probably the most shocking is
when Lola then goes after him because
she crashed her car
Lincoln looks absolutely terrified of
her she even ends up fighting him
because she wouldn't let him run over
his leg how crazy is that
it wasn't just Lincoln that couldn't
deal with this moment it really went
just a bit overboard even for the
viewers space invader space invader is
also one of those episodes that focuses
on a single sister and her relationship
with Lincoln to be honest there are only
a few sisters Lincoln really gets along
with but Lynne is not one of them in
fact Lynne hardly gets along with anyone
because she's so competitive but in
Space Invader she's also incredibly rude
to Lincoln after Lincoln lets her stay
in his room
fans have pointed out that although they
can be funny with each other this
episode showed how uncomfortable Lincoln
gets with Lynne sure she has her sense
of humor but she completely insulted
Lincoln's room and didn't even display
one ounce of beam grateful
and by the way Lincoln looks at her you
can really tell that he's hating it and
then there's the joke Lynne makes about
the lack of balls in his room the small
paws and Lincoln's face indicate a clear
innuendo he now I'm noticing a complete
lack of balls in this room oh and the UK
version of the same episode actually
edited out this scene because it was so
inappropriate
Lincoln clearly had enough but so did
nickelodeon who decided to put an end to
the inappropriate jokes we really felt
for Lincoln in this episode luan in
general vloggers have also pointed out
Lincoln's complicated relationship with
his sister Louann there really isn't a
specific episode in which Lincoln can't
deal with his jokester sister because it
seems like he's exhausted every single
time
she makes a pun the fans of the show
pointed out that LuAnn and Lincoln don't
really interact but when they do she
just makes jokes and puns the two don't
have an actual relationship with each
other and LuAnn isn't really aware she
could make Lincoln feel uncomfortable as
a matter of fact she kind of makes
everyone uncomfortable when she goes
overboard with her jokes sure that's her
style but we kind of wish her and
Lincoln would actually get along
who knows maybe season four will bring
us some extra LuAnn and Lincoln screen
time and maybe it will all be so
negative fans have also pointed out that
the April Fool's episode from season one
is the one that convinced them of Luanne
and Lincoln's weird relationship seems
like just about everyone is tired of
Luann's constant jokes what do you think
is Luanne being unfair to Lincoln do you
wish the two had a better relationship
let us know in the comments
we aren't letting you know until April
2nd sleuth or Consequences sleuth or
Consequences gives us an insight into
Lucy and Lincoln's relationship well
it's not ideal but you get along a lot
more than some of the other members of
the household although it's very clear
that Lincoln totally covered for Lucy in
this episode it's still not fair how he
was treated it all started when Lucy
clogged the family toilet and because
Lincoln knows her so well he knows who
did it
he tells her she needs to admit to what
she did instead of hiding it and make
the situation worse
but for some reason Lincoln decides to
claim responsibility of clogging the
toilet and he immediately gets yelled at
instead of Lucy you couldn't tell he was
done with the sisters but it was one of
those moments when we wish he would just
really stand up for himself it was
really unfair of Lucy to not admit to
what she did and let brain can take the
fall it just shows how slightly
dysfunctional their relationship can be
and we just really don't appreciate how
Lincoln was treated here he basically
knew Lucy did it by knowing her too well
that his other sisters didn't doubt him
for a single second that's kind of
unfair isn't it braw and the family
this entire episode was extremely
difficult to watch
even though Lincoln isn't the youngest
kid it really does resonate with every
youngest kid in the family all Lincoln
wanted to do was get food from the
kitchen but because one of his sisters
was cooling off in it after a fight he
couldn't seriously he wanted food and
they didn't allow him to go in because
someone else had issues with their anger
he then wanted to watch monster truck
rally on TV but his sisters didn't allow
him because it would provoke his sisters
really he's later told why Laurie and
linear acting like this it's because
they bought the same dress and are angry
at each other because one of them will
have to bring it back seriously that was
the basis of the entire argument and it
meant Lincoln wasn't allowed to enter
any room in the house sounds a bit
unfair right
Lincoln was clearly flabbergasted
throughout the entire episode and we
can't really blame him we still don't
know what was going on there or why this
was turned into such a big deal
why can they just cool off in one of the
rooms and let everyone else have a
normal day no such luck
this entire episode made us really feel
for Lincoln were made to believe that
Lincoln was actually bad luck so
naturally it's just not a good episode
it's actually the second divorce episode
of the loud sisters ganging up on
Lincoln throughout the entire episode
Lincoln's trying to win back his family
trust even though it's not his fault
they lost trust to him to begin with and
it was all because Lincoln didn't cheer
for Lynne at her game and made her team
lose their winning streak later on the
rest of his sister's ban him from
witnessing any of their activities which
is really quite sad come on guys did the
entire family really believe that
quickly that Lincoln's the bad guy in
all of this we really feel for him
throughout the episode Lincoln's treated
like the worst case ever and it's really
disappointing to see this behavior
coming from his sisters Lincoln of
course make sure this treatment allows
him to stay at home and play video games
but come on this was just unfair and you
could see Lincoln was really stressed
out for the entire episode he really
does get picked on a lot but there's one
more episode where he could've easily
lost his mind
heavy metal in this episode Lincoln gets
bullied at school and we all know by now
that his sisters make the situation even
worse bloggers have also pointed out
that this is by far one of the worst
loud house episodes ever fans have
pointed out that every loud sister was
so out of their regular character for
this entire episode it really ruins the
atmosphere on top of that Lincoln also
has to deal with trying to separate his
sisters from fighting at home so he
really doesn't have it easy at all
there's a moment in which the sisters
actually look delighted that Lincoln is
getting picked on by a girl and clearly
he really hates it the episode touches
on an important issue of bullying but
presents it in a strange way we later of
course learned that Ronnie an actually
likes Lincoln which is why she bullied
him but that's definitely not the only
reason why someone would bully someone
else
Lincoln sisters definitely didn't do him
any favors by not standing by his side
when they've realized he was getting
bullied by a girl what do you think do
you have any other loud house moments in
your head that were terrible for Lincoln
let us know in the comments and that's
it for our video don't forget to give it
a big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]